nous on va prendre la direction petit f
on va retrouver notre envoyé spécial
johnattan walsh étant donné les
circonstances on va pas le faire
attendre bonjour de linthal vous êtes au
coeur de la capitale ukrainienne pour
france 24 on nous signale d'ici des
bombardements au petit matin à kiev à ce
que vous le confirmer quelle est la
situation à l'heure où l'on se parle
foot et je ne peux pas vous confirmer
qu'il y a il ya quelque chose
d'inhabituel pour le dire ainsi à kiev
aujourd'hui nous nous avons entendu
effectivement des tirs d'artillerie
durant durant la nuit nous les avons
entendus encore il ya quelques minutes à
l'endroit où je me trouve mais c'est
quelque chose de permanent c'est quelque
chose de quotidien à kiev et c'est la
plupart du temps en périphérie de kiev
et en particulier à l'ouest et au nord
nous nous trouvons nous en plein en
plein centre ville je peux vous donner
une expérience que nous avons eu hier
lorsque nous nous sommes rendus à aubes
olonne dans l'est dans les faubourgs
nord de kiev pour pour aller couvrir le
bombardement de cet immeuble qui a été
qui a été complètement soufflé nous
étions sur place avec avec mon collègue
james andré et l'explication que nous
avons reçus de nombre de forces de
l'ordre sur place c'est que le lâche le
bombardement de cet immeuble n'était en
fait aurait en fait pu être beaucoup
plus grave et que c'est une partie
seulement du missile qui serait tombée
parce que il aurait été il aurait été la
cible de la défense anti aérienne
ukrainienne alors tout ça nous n'avons
aucune possibilité de le vérifier
clairement donc je ne voudrais pas trop
m'avancer mais est ce que cette
explosion est ce que cette destruction
d'immeubles qui a été qui a été donnée
par la fp ce matin est une est une
situation similaire on va le savoir dans
très peu de temps mais voilà pour
l'instant difficile évidemment de donner
des informations claires par rapport par
rapport à ces informations voilà cette
frappe de zlatan bonjour elle
concernerait une banlieue de kiev la
ville de sya tôt chine ce qui pour être
précis avec james andré vous êtes rendu
hier du côté de cas s'il qui placés dans
le sud de la capitale c'est un verrou
stratégique vers qui f
invisible un problème de liaison en tout
cas de sont avec vous je n'attache pas
si vous vous nous entendez on
vouvoiement nous entend pas
mal on retrouvera peut-être johnatan
watch mois plus tard alors l'entend
visiblement ça y est c'est rétabli
johnatan on le disait vous êtes partir
en reportage à bacilles qu'yves
oui absolument nous nous sommes rendus à
facile tifa à 40 km au sud de la
capitale ukrainienne vassil qui se
trouve sur cet axe sud qui est
absolument crucial pour pour la défense
de la capitale
nous avons vu beaucoup de beaucoup de
militaires beaucoup de volontaires
également ukrainien de la défense
territoriale il faut savoir que c'est un
hub
militaire 7 cette ville de vassil kif
sur le sur la route qui part qui part
vers rodez ça nous avons notamment
rencontré le chef des volontaires sains
d un des chefs principaux des
volontaires sur place qui nous a parlé
de sa détermination évidemment à
défendre à défendre la ville en tout cas
ce qui était frappant quand nous nous
sommes rendus sur place ça ça contraste
beaucoup avec ce qu'on peut voir au nord
ou à l'ouest de kiev c'était le calme
qui régnait dans la rue et en même temps
la facilité que nous avons eu à nous
rendre havas il kiffe alors juste une
juste une petite une petite note quand
même pour tempérer tout ça c'est que
nous avons vu beaucoup de véhicules
militaires sur la route qui transitaient
dans un sens et dans l'autre mais ça n'a
évidemment rien d'exceptionnel dans
situation de guerre dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons aujourd'hui de matane
walsh depuis kiev avec james andré
derrière la caméra merci beaucoup de
matane